I'm not saying whoever got nominated
didn't deserve to get nominated but when
you think about everything that that
he's doing in that film and and what
I've said when I've been talking about
Tom's performance in this film we give
actors so much credit in movies for
performing skills for playing
instruments or singing or gaining weight
and losing weight but and the skills
that Tom is putting on display in Top
Gun
um and so many of his movies that's
that's a product of you know thousands
of hours practiced and I think we we
don't realize how much work and effort
goes into that and I think a lot of the
time we associate performances on screen
with with effort we like to applaud
effort
um and I think Tom does it so seamlessly
that you don't you don't necessarily
realize